Question number one. Is the Tawi prayer
a sunnah or is it a fud? Can a person
miss it?
Alhamdulillah.
As far as the question is concerned that
isawi or isam
during Ramadan is it or is it a sunnah
>> as we discussed earlier a beloved
prophet wasallam said it's mentioned in
say bkari volume number three in the
book of
hadith number 2012
and it gives how Muhammad sallallahu
alaihi wasallam offered in the mosque
during Raman and people join joined him.
The next day the news spread and when he
came the next day the full mosque was
filled. The third day it was overflowing
and fourth day purposely though the
mosque was overflowing he did not come
out for the tawi which people call
>> and when he came for the fud salah he
said not that he did not know that
people were waiting for me but I
purposely he didn't come because I
didn't want offering
is a fur. So from this hadith we come to
know that it is not a fur.
But the other hadith of say bkari volume
number three book of sarawi hadith
number 20009 the beloved prophet said
that anyone who offers the night prayer
in Ramadan
with belief and seeking Allah's reward
all his past sins will be forgiven. So
based on this you come to know though
it's not a it's a very important sunnah
it's
that means a very highly recommended
sunnah of the prophet though it's not a
fur it's sun very highly recommended
sunnah and no Muslim should miss it
unless he really has a valid reason he
should as far as possible offer it and
seek Allah's reward so all his sins will
be forgiven